herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
religion alles wirkliche leben ist
begegnung das sagte einst der jüdischen
religionsphilosophen martin buber bei
mir begegnen sich heute zwei gäste bei
denen man sagen kann zwei welten treffen
aufeinander
der benediktinerpater anselm grün und
der islamwissenschaftler und koran
übersetzer ahmad milad karimi
ich freue mich sehr dass sie heute hier
sind wird uns auch unser besser ja herr
grün herr karimi würden sie aus ihrer
erfahrung der aussage von martin buber
das alles wirkliche leben begegnung ist
zustimmen
ja sicher in der begegnung lief ich
selber kennen und in der begegnung habe
ich ein die welt des anderen und nur
wenn ich eintauchen in die welt des
anderen kann ich sie verstehen oder
begegnungen gibt es immer nur
gegeneinander
den kann ich nur beipflichten
entwicklung etwas besonderes weil es
menschen geht das geht einfach zwischen
menschlichkeit und das ist etwas was nur
in der begegnung sich ereignen kann das
ist so das besondere einer begegnung die
man sonst nicht so einholen kann und hat
das vielleicht auch etwas ganz
spezielles in der religion diese
begegnung ist das speziell in der
religion wichtig ja in der tat gerade
also die ganze religiosität besteht ja
gerade in einer mehrfachen begegnung
nichts geht es um die begegnung mit dem
ganz andere nimmt mit gott dass die so
sagen dass das herz der religion auf der
anderen seite geht es auch um die
begegnung zwischen menschen die
begegnung mit der schöpfung die
begegnung mit den tieren selbst
begegnung da all das sind grundthemen
der religion
jetzt haben sie ja dieses buch zusammen
geschrieben jüngst es heißt im herzen
der spiritualität
sie überlegen sich da wie christen und
muslime sich begegnen können
nun weiß man ja aber das in der heutigen
zeit sich die traditionellen religionen
nicht unbedingt großer freude nennen
können das heißt kirchen leeren sich
weniger leute bekennen sich zu diesen
traditionellen religionen
ich habe mich gefragt ist diesbezüglich
eigentlich nicht wichtiger zu überlegen
wie können sich ungläubiger oder
säkularisierte menschen mit gläubigen
menschen treffen wie können sie sich
verständigen und verstehen
ja ich glaube man muss nicht dieses zwei
perspektiven gegeneinander ausspielen
ich bin es ist schon sehr wichtig was
sie ansprechen nämlich die begegnung
zwischen denjenigen die man als
gläubiger würden pauschal begriff geben
soll und nun gläubig bezeichnen kann wer
jetzt schon ungläubig wenn es überhaupt
gibt dann gibt es in der tat die die
notwendigkeit dieser begegnung weil es
auch darum geht zu hören wir auf ein
ganz anderer lebensentwurf funktionieren
kann und wie man auch dort voneinander
lernen kann ich glaube das ist auch ein
ziemlich wichtiger punkt und auf der
anderen seite kann das nicht genügen
weil auch religionen sich was zu sagen
haben das heißt diese begegnung von der
wir beide gesprochen haben oder sprechen
immer noch ist etwas was was wirklich
die religionen selbst auch fördern
das liegt so seien in meiner religion
dem herzen meiner religion dass ich den
anderen finde das ist mit ihm ins
gespräch
das ist natürlich beim islam noch ganz
spezifisch weil er sich so stark auch
auf das christentum und das judentum
bezieht wie sehen sie das
gut sechs zur ersten frage ich glaube
auch den sogenannten ungläubigen ist
eine sehnsucht nach glauben sehnsucht
nach dem geheim
nach dem was sie übersteigt und unsere
aufgabe als religiöse menschen besteht
darin diese sehnsucht anzusprechen und
nicht ihnen ein system überzustülpen
dass das einen die was insofern ist der
dialog mit den sogenannten atheisten
auch eine herausforderung
unser gottesbild immer wieder in frage
zu stellen wie ist gott wirklich und
unsere begriffe von gott zugriff von
bildern gottes jenseits aller bilder und
das andere dialog der religionen ist
ganz wichtig weil erst mal in der
begegnung mit dem anderen spielt seine
spiritualität und dann geht es nicht um
recht haben sondern begegnung und
versuchen zu verstehen und um respekt
und achtung wurde das priorität ist
anderen und wenn dieser respekt da ist
da gibt es kein gegeneinander
wie sie ja leider in den letzten jahren
doch immer wieder der fall war
wir konnten kann kommen danach sehr
gerne noch mal auf dieses thema ich
möchte sie noch dazu konkret fragen was
jetzt auch ausgeführt haben sie selber
sind ja auch autor mindestens 300 bücher
sie sind viel unterwegs sind ja auch
berater von managern
man hat das gefühl in der heutigen
gesellschaft gibt es war das wie eine
sinnkrise wie nehmen sie das war auch in
ihrer rolle jetzt die assoziierte sind
krise aber zugleich eben eine suche sind
und gerade wenn die führungs seminare
geben vorträge für firmen halte dir
nicht zur religiösen kontext haben
merke ich doch dass sie sich ansprechen
lassen und dass sie spüren nur dass
ausgehend von der rationalität von
zahlen dass es zu reden um es von
menschen ausgehen und verbrauchswerte
nicht nur einfach von menschen ausgehen
was hält den menschen nach dem menschen
wert wollen das sind eben die werte also
auch bei managern die sich durchaus die
offenheit für religiosität
nur diese religiosität wie sie leider
ihren kristallklaren manchmal verkündet
worden ist nicht moralisieren
daherkommen sondern sondern als hilfe
als mann mit der inneren quelle in
berührung zu kommen und da sind ja beide
religionen wichtige wege zu erinnern
quelle und in ein ziel zu keinen sinn zu
vermitteln
das erleben sie selber in ihrem alltag
sagen ja aber könnte es denn auch sein
ich weiß ja nicht genau wie die leute zu
ihnen kommen aber das ist genau die
leute sind eben sowieso schon suchen
sind die dann zu ihm kommen und quasi
hilfe suchen was ist mit den anderen die
eben diese dieses quasi sind angebot
könnte man ja auch sagen gar nicht erst
suchen
es gibt natürlich bei den männern auch
leute die nur durch zahlen gehen aber
ich möchte die nicht verurteilen ich
wollte die anderen stärken und so dass
die die nur auf zu haus gehen merkten
sie sind irgendwo nach zugleich könnte
man sagen also nicht die vorreiter so
nachzügler aber klar kennt jemand
verschlossen ist dann kann ich dich
gewalt aufbrechen
aber trotzdem habe ich auch die hoffnung
dass selbst im verschlossenen menschen
angesehen so ist jetzt ist dass sie wie
gesagt betitelt im herzen dass
spiritualität und spiritualität dass er
doch auch heutzutage ein modebegriff
geworden und erlöst gewissermaßen auch
den begriff der religiosität ab ist
diese offenheit des titels nicht auch
ein problem für ihr projekt wurde
natürlich ist ein modewort und man darf
nicht es gibt ja auch menschen die von
speed ohne gott sprechen genau aber wir
sprechen über das priorität vom geist
also ist eigentlich heißt vom geist
gottes leben und auch im islam geht es
ja darum
vom geist gottes zu leben und in diesem
sinn sprechen wir von spiritualität und
nicht in dem wagen sind wir heute in der
gesellschaft wird verkündet wird
möchten sie etwas hinzufügen ja
vielleicht weil man sich am besten den
begriff der religion da nicht wieder
überflüssig wird er hinzu ich glaube das
war nicht die intention vielmehr war die
intention zu zeigen worin eigentlich die
religion gegründet ist im grunde
genommen jeder kann religiös sein wenn
er will
aber was ist damit überhaupt gesagt also
wenn ich einfach fünfmal am tag beten
ein gläubiger muslim ist das schon
religion also habe ich das in meiner
aufgabe als mensch erfüllt ist ein wenig
mir wäre das einfach so wenig
das wäre das könnte man einfach einen
guten roboter auch programmieren und
roboter würde viel viel genauer die
gebete vorführen als wir menschen die
fehlbare sind es geht hier darum ob das
was ich da tue auch was mit mir macht
also diese innere bereicherung die aus
dem aus diesem gefüge der religion
einbricht
in unserer eigenen verschlossenen
geführt also in all dem was man mir
stellen niemanden verurteilen aber in
gewisser weise ist ja schon fraglich was
ist ein leben bedeutet wenn man dieses
leben nur kalkulierend vollzieht und
dieses wassers weiter an soll mir mal
sehn sucht beschreibt oder geheimnis des
lebens das ist eine andere dimension die
gerade religionen ja zum zuzustimmen
gebracht haben weil sie an diesen solle
sagen also eine grüne jugend stifter
denken sind ja nicht gewöhnliche
menschen gewesen etwas an ihnen ist auch
in gewisser weise verrückt sie sind
etwas
ihre verkündung und denken sie an
bergpredigt und das ist nicht etwas
womit ein einfacher politiker gut was
anfangen kann
das hat bismarck glaube ich sehr genervt
aber trotzdem einfach mit wie stellen
werden konnte aber es ist ja etwas ganz
besonderes was dort so erklingen kommt
ist es was wir als geistigkeit ein
bisschen beschreiben als diese
unheimliche fülle dieser überfluss das
ist das was uns als thema vorgespielt
jetzt habe ich ein spannendes bild
gefunden auf twitter es wurde gepostet
von einem religionswissenschaftler coco
von stuckrad ein gast von mir sogar er
hat dieses bild gepostet village und ihr
spiritualität selbst sogar in berlin
aufgenommen
was halten sie der von religion tötet
spiritualität hättet ich würde regionen
spirit nicht so gegeneinander stellen
natürlich gibt es die religion die nur
den stücken station ist und nur
äußerlich ist aber man muss ja auch
sagen dass viele menschen in der
religion spirituelle menschen sind und
dass ich ihnen zustimmung fünfmal gebet
macht doch nicht denn vom muslim auch
die den formen christen aus gebete die
äußerung von sind hilfen damit unser
geistig wandelt und heute meinen manche
sie brauchen keine dramen sie sind nur
spirituell aber das ist das wo sie
vergeblich auch gegenüber wenn überhaupt
nicht gibt die meinen sie sind schon
spittel ohne dass sie formen brauchen
und das ist für mich als placebo zu
sagen wenn ich keine form und habe dann
dann verstand winterlich also dann
dann werde ich auch meine spezialität
lang immer schwächer werden
natürlich es geht um das rettende und
das retten ist der geist die religion in
der religion kann sich viel negatives
vermischen und insofern die aggressive
religion oder in amerika die tea party
die christliche religion auch so so als
aggressiv gegründet von der könnte man
natürlich sagen dass sie tötet und die
parität ist dass man sagen die
frömmigkeit er das leben das ist das was
uns verbindet was muslime und christen
verbindet und was natürlich auch rettet
und nicht nicht tötet und kann sie damit
etwas anfangen herr karin eigentlich
wenig weil es einfach unglaublich und
differenziert ist ja gut das ist in
einer toilette handy sein das ist nicht
differenziert ja aber das ist schon
gegenstand einer solchen gesprächs wird
muss man darüber differenzierter glaube
ich daran gehen wenn religion religion
spiritualität gerät ist dann wenn wir
alle fragen was ist wenn ich mit
religion gemeint
und das ist das undifferenzierte in der
tat kann man es auch gleich umdrehen und
sagen es beschlossen es gibt genug
sektiererischer bewegungen die menschen
vereinnahmen ihre freiheit rauben mit
ihm machen was sie wollen weil sie
einfach gerade die spiritualität
missdeuten das ist eine sehr gefährliche
angelegenheit
ich denke an esoterische bewegungen die
dieses all das ist eigentlich nicht
gemeint wenn wir aus der perspektive der
religion von spiritualität reden ich
würde sagen so was wie eine religion
ohne spiritualität ist unglaublich kalt
hat einfach keine pulsationen qualität
was das wäre ja also wie gesagt wie also
wenn man einfach gar nicht nur nur die
formen beachtet nur die die gebote
beachtet ohne zu fragen was diese gebote
eigentlich keinen sinn haben
das heißt wie sollen gerade ich spreche
für mich als gläubiger muslim
meine gebete halten und die halte ich
auch so weit ich kann aber mit mit liebe
aber die gewohnheit islam quasi ja genau
also im grunde genommen ich soll fünfmal
am tag beten aber jedes mal wenn ich
beim gebet steht muss ich mich fragen
was tue ich da eigentlich und eine
spiritualität ohne religion beginnt
gerade das was diese formlose alle haben
sich lieb und das ist mir auch dann zu
wenig und zu konturlos
insofern würde ich die beiden verbinden
und das als das verstehen was sichert
und gewissen
trotzdem spricht es etwas ganz wichtiges
an ich glaube einen gewissen zeitgeist
dass man mit spiritualität das versteht
was eben nicht institutionalisierte
religion ist institutionalisierte
religion empfindet man als beengend eben
mit den ganzen äußerlichkeiten und
weshalb ist das so was haben diese
traditionellen religionsgemeinschaften
falsch gemacht dass ein solcher satz im
öffentlichen raum einfach hin
geschrieben wird und dass er dann sogar
im internet landet und jetzt sogar in
unserer sendung weil es hat wahrheit
daran hier in der in der lebensweise der
menschen
und was sagen die religion begehrt
gemacht wo es zwei dinge sehen die
religion als tradition ist tradiert den
reichtum von spiritualität aber völlig
und als gemeinschaft ist immer auch in
gefahr
das macht damit spielt und und die macht
korrumpiert richtige religion und
natürlich unter dem namen der religion
kann man kriege führen und usw
insofern ist dieser negative aspekt von
religionen in der gesellschaft heute
präsent aber das ist eben der kasimir
auch sagt der verfälschung der religion
hat eine sagen ja korruption optimiert
es ihm also wenn das beste verdorben
wird ist es ganz schlimm und religion
ist dann nicht verdorben worden als
macht verbunden und mit politischen
interessen und dann ist es gefährlich
weil dann die ration fehlt oder den
menschenrechten all das fehlt im namen
gottes wir dann gemordet und das ist
dieser negative aspekt aber ich bin eben
auch beides verbinden weil es gibt auch
betritt bewegung ist da gebe ich ihnen
recht tiefe einnahmen diese mensch noch
töten
es gibt der später die flucht in die
grandiosität das erlebe ich immer wieder
von menschen das bedeutet was genau
verfolgt von therapeut und erklärt ihnen
sind beziehungsunfähig sie betrauern das
nicht und der glaube könne durchaus
helfen dann mit diesem schmerz umzugehen
aber sie finde die grandiosität die
sagen wir sind schon so schmolz mit dem
göttlichen gebrauch einer grippe tieren
und dann über überspringt man das rein
alltägliche und flieden die
spiritualität religiosität wie immer man
das denn will
aber das ist dann die grandiosität eine
vielleicht heikle frage aber ist das
denn nicht das was man auch im kloster
macht dass man sagt man braucht keine im
monat natürlich zwischenmenschliche
beziehungen aber ich meine der haut
bezugspunkt ist ja bei ihnen jetzt
christus oder nicht ja aber da er
gebändigt ist ganz nüchtern das
kriterium ist ob eine wahrhaft gott
sucht aber das zeigt sich an drei
stellen oder alfa hat gottesdienst open
fähig sich auf gemeinschaft reinzulassen
und bereit sich in der arbeit fördern zu
lassen
also bin ich immer die realität
kontrolle hatte machte jetzt ist aber
unmöglich im miteinander und hat zwei
linke hände und taktet an
das ist der falsche schüttelt hätte mir
viel über die spiritualität in der
gesellschaft über das bild das ihre
qualität in der gesellschaft gerät würde
mich interessieren was haben sie für
einen bezug zur spiritualität was ist
das für sie ja also wie islamischer
perspektive ist eigentlich unglaublich
reizvoll weil die mystische spirituelle
traditionen des islams ist eigentlich
keine rand bewegung
klaren islam den orthodoxen islam und
daneben gebe es auch noch irgendwelche
verrückte persönlichkeiten figuren die
auch spirituelle waren genauso ist das
nicht sondern schon sehr früh beginnt so
etwas wie die verbindung zwischen geist
und geistigkeit ich glaube einer der
ersten die großartigen persönlichkeit
den islamischer probierens die gerade
das vollzogen haben wir eine eigene
person im berg ist avision also in china
der so etwas wie er denken also wirklich
aristotelische logik und geistigkeit
miteinander verbindet und danach dann
sie müssen schauen dann gibt es wirklich
eine eigene traditionen und dann
unterschiedliche formen wie gerade diese
geistigkeit artikuliert wird zum
beispiel durch liebes mystik aber auch
durch erkenntnis mystik oder auch durch
ekstase es gibt unterschiedliche formen
und ausprägungen dieser dieser
geistigkeit die man auch im arabisch als
also etwas wie malaria oder das ist
wirklich etwas was von nicht material
ist also das wenige was das material
überschreitet ok genau das ist etwas was
ganz bewegend wird und auch bereits
koranische grundgelegt ist also doch an
ihr buch heißt auf arabisch wie man es
auch gehört übrigens auch ähnlich
nämlich geist und gott haucht von seinem
eigenen geister in menschen hinein damit
sie zum leben erweckt werden die rüben
seele geist als prinzip des lebens etwas
was wir auch die kirchentradition auch
kennen das ist etwas was muslime dann
unglaublichen bewegt und fragen ja wie
ist unsere begegnung mit gott genauer
tituliert also wie erreiche ich gott in
dieser welt und über dieser welt hinaus
was muss ich tun damit mein leben
geradeaus und in der begegnung gottes
verwirklicht wird
und diesen weg auf diesem weg zu sein
scheint es mit dem islam zu begründen
und wie ist es für sie persönlich dieser
weg wie kommen sie da hin was ich ganz
interessant finde in mehreren ihrer
bücher schreiben sie von rilke von den
gedichten von rainer maria rilke und sie
schreiben sogar von
so genannten ring sucht jedenfalls
nennen sie das sind wir quasi
autobiografie so und auch in diesem buch
wo sich gemeinsam über spiritualität und
religiosität schreiben haben sie recht
getrennt was hat er mit ihrer
religiosität zu tun ja wie soll ich
meine seele halten dass sie nicht an
deine rührt sagt rinke rickes sprache
will chris tiefe hat mir schon sehr früh
bewegt also als sich so langsam
deutschland viel deutsch zu lernen in
deutschland vor ungefähr 22 jahren war
er mein begleiter also jemand der
unglaublich herausfordernd ist aber sie
merken auch ich habe mich danach gesucht
ob er rainer maria rilke heißt oder
april ist der name vollkommen egal und
tradition für nicht wichtig sondern das
gesagt und wie rilke die wirklichkeit
beschreibt die linke meine gefühle in
anspruch nimmt was rilke in mir öffnet
dann ist eigentlich egal dass erreger
ist das heißt das ja nicht vielleicht
unbedingt ein muslimischer figur ist ob
vielleicht sehr vom islam und begeistert
ist
seinen ganzen engel bilder sagt schreibt
der selbst in einem brief sind wir näher
aus dem islamischen kontext entnommen
das ist etwas was meine eigentliche
liebe zu diesen tradition eigentlich
geweckt hat ich bin in der tat ein
mystiker gefangen im körper eines
philosophen und aus diesem tag nicht es
ist aber ein schönes leben
was würden sie dazu sagen können sie
jetzt mit poesie und spiritualität und
religiosität kann sie da auch damit was
anfangen natürlich priorität ist für
mich auch die mystische tradition und
sind
das christentum hat eine ganz große
mystische traktion angefangen von krisen
kirchenvätern oder angefangen von paulus
und oder lukas und giesenkirchen peter
das für mich wichtig die erfahrung
gottes also dass ich nicht nur über
rechthaberei und theologie sprechen
sondern wie kann ich gefahren gottes
formulieren
für mich heißt bietet einmal in den
kunden seele kommen in den raum der
stille wo gott in mir wohnt und dieses
gott in wir spüren das ist oft leute
lebenshilfe weil ich drei bin von der
wartung der menschen und da kann könnt
auch die verletzten worte nicht
hinbringen dass da ein aspekt das andere
ist dass priorität heißt für mich immer
durchlässiger zu werden film geist jesu
oder so etwas sagte dass er das licht
der welt
die frage was strahlt von mir aus ist
interessant ist dass dieses licht der
welt bei matthäus mehren moralisch
gedeutet wird die die leute erkennen
einen guten taten das will ich der welt
sind
bei lukas mystische sagt das auge ist
das licht es gab also das auge einfach
ist harmlos das ist der ganze körper
licht dass wenn als wenn wir von von
licht gottes licht christi durchdrungen
ist dann strahlt auch was aus das ist
für mich das ziel von spirito etwas
auszustrahlen
in dieser welt und das ist der
lebenslange legte verwandlungen wer von
diesem geist prägen zu lassen und nicht
mein egoistischen geist hineinzubringen
und das meine ich mit flucht in die
qualität manche sprechen vom ego tod
aber merkten gar nicht viel ego sich
dahinter verbirgt und deswegen bin ich
skeptisch gegen zu große worte weil
dahinter sind in den geschäften sollten
jetzt haben sie auch von der flucht
gesprochen hätten sie haben das
eigentlich schon angedeutet sie sind als
13-jähriger jahr aus afghanistan
geflüchtet und dann zwei jahre später
nett war in deutschland angekommen
sie nennen ihre flucht in einem
interview eine spirituelle erfahrung das
kann man nicht verstehen können sie uns
das erklären was was meinen sie mit dem
ja ich will sie nicht müssen
im nachhinein wer glaubt ist ein
flüchtling
das bedeutet dass die flucht
auch mein leben geprägt hat und auch mit
lehrern und erkenntnissen verbunden ist
die ich unglaublich für wichtig erachte
zum beispiel bevor ich irgendwo vorwege
flüchteten aus afghanistan war für mich
so etwas wie heimat überhaupt keinen
begriff heimat es vielleicht auch dort
wo man nicht über heimat nachdenkt aber
auf der flucht irgendwann ist mir
klargeworden irgendetwas passiert hier
und spätestens dann als wir in
deutschland angekommen sind und ich
immer angeschaut wurde
als ein fremder als ausländer smeekes
und später wurde ich dann zu muslimen
eben etwas was was sich verschoben hat
und mir war dann irgendwann mal klar
eigentlich dieser begriff dieser idee
von heimat als ein ort in dem man ist
ist eigentlich verfehlt insofern war
afghanistan als ort niemals meine heimat
seiner heimat ist so etwas wie zu einem
thema was gerade auch sie bewegt und
eben nächsten glaubt themenheft einfach
leben erscheinen wird nämlich
heimatgefühle sind gefühle die die ich
habe wenn ich ja wenn ich herrliche
gedicht aus dem hinter meines vaters
höhere oder wenn meine mutter da ist da
da ist etwas anderes was mit der flucht
verbundene geht die ganze
zerbrechlichkeit des lebens wird einen
gewann
denn es ist ja nicht nur das ich
geflüchtet bin sondern etwas von mir ist
hat die flucht ergriffen etwas ist auch
geblieben
aber haben sie den glauben nie verloren
deswegen es klingt alles so
gewissermaßen schon optimistisch positiv
seien gerade nicht sondern der glaube
war viel subtiler formuliert und
artikuliert gerade dann als wenn wir von
leiter frauen sprechen
ich habe gezweifelt und gehadert
aber gerade das davon lebt ja der glaube
ist nicht etwa so etwas machst meiner
perspektive meine rote rosarote brille
anziehen und dann ist alles gut sondern
glaube fordert uns heraus glaube schenkt
auch tiefe unruhe
und stillen raum all das kann ich nur
unterschreiben auch dass islamischer
perspektive aber der glaube erweckt in
uns haupt so etwas wie unruhe und aus
dieser heraus zu leben dass man nicht
immer wieder fragt darf ich heute abend
noch schlafen darf ich die augen
schließen bin ich wahrhaft gläubig bin
und was bedeutet dass die augen einfach
zu schließen
und ich tue es mir schwer zu schlafen
weil ich weiß was bedeutet dies was
heißt das dass ich überhaupt schlafen
davon andere menschen die nicht anders
sind als ich unglaubliche leiter
erfahrungen durchleben müssen nur weil
sie woanders sind und wo entsteht
sozusagen religiöse verantwortung sie
hören das ist nicht einfach moralis muss
also dann das ist etwas was mich sehr
bewegt wenn das da ist dann ist die
flucht ein unglaublich wichtiger
wichtiges element in meinem leben
gewesen
ich sehe schon sie haben das
gewissermaßen wirklich auch in ihr leben
so jetzt integriert das ist quasi eben
dieses prägende element zum auf die
ganze lebensspanne quasi ausgeweitet
wurde
ich möchte hier weiter gehen nämlich zu
etwas das es schon angesprochen haben
sie schreiben im nachwort dieses buches
auch das im gespräch zwischen den
religionen die spiritualität eben das
eigentlich verbindende sei es sein die
spirituellen traditionen die
zueinanderfinden sufismus christliche
mystik die zueinander gehören so
schreiben sie das jetzt berufen sie sich
eben auf diese mystische strömungen der
religionen und ich frage mich wie
repräsentativ ist es wirklich für die
gesamte tradition
ich denke im christentum ist die
mystischen tradition zentrale so
wenigstens bis zum jahr tausende dann
auch später natürlich die deutsche
meister eckehart spanische mystik
natürlich gab es dann in der aufklärung
einbruch wo die mystik negativ gesehen
worden ist oder in der evangelischen
theologie karl barth
für den war müsste kein schimpfwort und
heute ist sie sowohl katholische
theologen ist ohne musik ist dass
christus im organismus und dass das hat
der viele aus der kirche heraus
getrieben sie wollten viele menschen
suchen
spezielle erfahrungen und da ist der
mystik für mich sicher wichtig und dass
sie könig gesagt dann über heimat ist
für mich auch entscheidend also die
deutsche sprache va bene der heimat und
geheimnisse ein sein kann und über das
geheimnis und so etwas ist was größeres
dass sich bei sich selbst daheim sein
oder hilde domin meint nicht deutschland
ist die heimat und ihre sprache die
deutsche sprache ist ihre heimat
und so ist wie sie sich auch die sprache
die presse sprach die heimat und genauso
ist also ich hatte auch vorher kurz
angedeutet dass sophies muss also also
passt auf arabisch diese strömung ist
eigentlich einer der lebendigsten der
wache traditionen im islam immer schon
gewesen
das heißt eine eine tradition die die
sich vornehmlich auch lyrisch ausdrückt
gerade die praktische müssten eigentlich
alle persischen mystiker sind auch nicht
von hafez den noch gültigen schützt aber
auch romy denn man hier kennt aber mein
bereich viele andere in germany sa - ja
auch immer heissen mögen aber die
arabischen die zwar nicht lyrisch
unterwegs sind also wie der große basar
aber erst sinn für eine subtile
versöhnung der unterschiedlichen
traditionen man einfach einen blick
dafür hat dass beide seiten eigentlich
ins leere gehen anders ausdrückt
vielleicht kann man ganz modern sein das
in uns menschen 22 seelen wir zwei
seelen in der brust nämlich einmal einen
sinn für klarheit für geist für logische
zusammenhänge für kontrolle für für
entwürfe für planungen
das alles ist gut aber gerne seite ist
auch das etwas anderes ist also wie
seinen romantisch zu sein
man kann man sich sein und dennoch
rational unterwegs sein und gerade die
verbindung von den beiden ist glaube ich
das was die religionen zeigen dass sie
einfach nicht fremde sind sondern
zueinander gehören
und wenn es dann um eine art gespräch
zwischen den religionen geht merken sie
und das haben wir sehr früh gemerkt so
etwas gibt es ja gar nicht um religion
am noch nie miteinander gesprochen
wir sind nun mal menschen und wenn
menschen miteinander reden wollen die
aus unterschiedlichen religionen kommen
dann geht es darum dass sie aufeinander
zugehen dass ich einfach in den augen
schauen dass wir einfach voneinander
hören was ich zum ersten mal ich bin oft
in kirchen gewesen und bin immer noch
aber zum ersten mal hatte ich die
gelegenheit eine kirche aus den augen
von pater anselm zu sehen und betrachten
sie das mal das ist unglaublich seitdem
sehe ich die kirche ganz anders und das
ist für mich eine große bereicherung in
große auch anklang und affinität zu
einer religion den ich meine ist aber
vor der ich einfach mit staunen da stehe
und nicht vor fremdheit oder
unverständnis
ich sehe dass das ist ein sehr schöner
anblick ich möchte darauf dann auch
zurückkommen ich möchte aber zuerst noch
mal ganz kurz bei der musik bleiben weil
es jedoch real ist dass die wenigsten
leute diese beiden strömungen mit einer
mystischen strömung verbinden sondern
oft negative bilder haben davon sagen
die terrorismus sagen mir
frauenunterdrückung sagen wir
kindsmissbrauch das ist ja doch das was
man bei diesen religionen im vordergrund
hat dennis dann scheint es jetzt für den
leser dieses buches der sich sonst nicht
so auskennt damit sondern medial
geprägtes sonderbar plötzlich ein
solches buch über die mystischen
traditionen zu lesen dass es geht es
wirkt extrem gesagt vielleicht wie ein
wohlfühl islam oder ein wohlfühl
christentum selbst wenn natürlich die
mystiker alles andere als als wohlfühl
christen oder muslime waren sondern sehr
radikal oft auch da haben wir uns
einfach nicht ausgespart in dem buch
wir haben gerade den anfang haben
mitgemacht so fragen wie welche
stolpersteine eigentlich der dialog und
meine welche mit welchen bildern wir
beide besetzt
und klar haben wir probleme so etwas wie
gewalt im islam frauenunterdrückung die
wahrheitsfrage toleranz frage
all das sind fragen stolpersteine die
die wir haben müssen das heißt mystische
blick muss auch darin der wache blick
seien auch diese strippe steine zu
erkennen und versuchen darauf eine
antwort zu geben sie können zu recht
fragen über wünschen islam reden sie
denn das ist einfach ein schön ausgemalt
mystischer islam bingham mensch lebt nur
einfach bei sonderlinge und genau das
ist ja mein unser vorhaben gewesen zu
zeigen dass es nicht das ist sondern der
wahre islam den es nicht gibt ist der
sufismus deshalb weil es dort um eine
mine suche nach dem wahren geht also
wenn es so etwas wie den wahren islam
geben muss dann muss es im suche nach
dem wahren gegründet sein alles andere
ist schon keine religion mehr derjenige
der innerhalb einer religion nicht nach
der wahrheit sucht sondern so tut als
hätte er die wahrheit dann ist die
wahrheit für ihn etwas was nicht mehr
eine frage ist soll es ab haft geworden
nur gott und was lernen lehren alle
religionen ist gerade als wahrheit jene
figur die niemals verfügbar bleibt auch
das immer das unverfügbare können sie
definieren was religion ist ich kann es
ja gut definierte definition ist immer
schwierig aber ich habe schon bestimmen
aus der religion heraus was religiös ist
religion ist immer mit einem aspekt der
demut zu tun also wenn sie eine
religiöse menschen treffen und der nicht
demütig ist dann kann ich jetzt schon
sagen wir sagen als ein kriterium dafür
dann ist dort was schiefgelaufen demuth
bedeutete immer dass ich ihm ein lernen
da bin
und woher habe ich das das habe ich von
meinem profiten gewarnt denn immer auf
der suche nach der wahrheit war er ist
mir ein vorbild weil der prophet
muhammad immer auf der suche nach der
wahrheit war immer wie wasser die tiefe
gesucht hat und ich glaube darin ist er
mir auch ein vorbild das ist immer nicht
auf der oberfläche bleiben und sage eine
kirche ist dunkel groß eine gotische
kirche so viele bilder
da habe ich angst das ist meine
oberflächliche erste eindruck bin ich
habe dabei bleiben und sein
sie ist meine meinung weil das wir sind
ja meine erste eindrücke und das ist
auch dann war dann ist da was verloren
gegangen aber wenn ich da hingehen
christenmenschen anfangs um sage und
schreibe mir deine kirche und er ist mir
so beschreibt dass ich es verstehe dann
ist das schon eine wandlung vollzogen
ich möchte mit dem begriff der demut
weitergehen weil das ja durchaus sehr
wichtig in diesem dialog nämlich in
bezug auf diesen wahrheits und
absolutheitsanspruch der ja eigentlich
doch beide religionen für sich
beanspruchen
ich möchte von ihnen beiden wissen was
für abstriche mussten sie oder müssten
sie machen was muss man für abstriche
machen als religiöser mensch in einem
solchen dialog gut für mich ich kann ein
absolutheitsanspruch daher nicht leugnen
dass christus die offenbarung aber wir
müssen in einer demo zeigen dass wir
christen doch lange nicht das geheimnis
je so das geheimnis gottes erfasst daten
die man auch dem weg sind und wie hat
der dialog so wurden nicht lange
das muss gehört geholfen jesus auch mit
anderen augen zu sehen
unsere christlichen augen sind ja auch
einseitig aber dass für mich die bibel
und und das leben jesu die person jesu
die absolute selbstheilung gottes aber
wie jeder selbst mitteilung gottes durch
menschliche worte durch menschliche
strukturen überliefert wird ist da immer
oder verfälschung und deswegen heißt der
abstrich tat des absoluten anspruch
bedeutet für mich die perspektive des
politischen dennis muslim anzunehmen und
mit diesen augen dann neu ob jesus zu
schauen
sie geben mir ein gutes stichwort ich
meine eine schwierige passage im koran
ist ja die dass man sagt jesus wurde
nicht gekreuzigt bzw es kann nicht jesus
gewesen sein der gekreuzigt wurde sie
als ordensmann dass das muss ihnen doch
ein schmerz versetzen wie gehen sie
damit um
warum da ist man das so sieht
weil er ist es den großputz beten kann
nicht gekreuzigt werden natürlich kann
ich das so nicht akzeptieren werden für
mich ist die kreuzestheologie gibt auch
verfälschungen es gibt noch ist die
auslegung des des kreuzes aber für mich
ist dann fällt da schon etwas
entscheidendes dass dort jetzt ja als
vollendung der liebe gibt keine größere
lieber zu nehmen als ein leben hingibt
für seine freunde und insofern ist für
mich kreuz und auferstehung ist es schon
das zentrale aber ich denke im dialog
kann man auch spüren warum sagt mohammed
s und wie wie kann man das auch neue
weise verstehen
im grunde aber aus meiner perspektive
ich habe keine abstriche gemacht
ich habe keine islam jetzt hier dort
vertreten damit sowohl für islam für das
christentum wäre das war das wäre gerade
einfach fällig dialog aber ihnen das
dann weil sie gerne hören und die stelle
des schweden sind die einfach nicht
ausspricht
ich weiß im koran steht ja diese stelle
und das wird bestimmt haben die habe ich
erst recht ausgesprochen um ihn geradezu
zu ärgern
dann kommt der echte theologe aus ihm
raus der über karl rahner promoviert hat
und er zeigt mir wie differenziert auch
im theologisch auch daran gehen kann und
auch das tut aber spaß beiseite die die
der dialog und das was da entstanden ist
das ist ja keine neue religion dass wir
sagen können islam und christentum haben
sich begegnet und daraus etwas neues ins
virtuelle bewegung geworden
das war nicht die situation dass auch
nicht am ende herausgekommen sondern
differenzen sind geblieben
und dafür will sie sehen immer wieder
wichtig zu betonen ist aus aber wenn ich
sie noch kurz darauf ansprechen kann in
bezug auf user jesus sie sagen etwas
ganz interessantes und da möchte ich
nachfragen wie sie sich das erklären sie
schreiben der weg dieses land führe zu
jesus ohne ihn sei kein spiritueller weg
des islam möglich ja in der tat ist
nicht einfach jesus sondern es man jesus
ist mein prophet unter propheten gibt es
keine unterschiede
da wirst du jesus für taucht man sich
einfach durch den koran hindurch reisen
es gibt eine eigene suche die mit maria
mit titeln ist und da geht es um die
geburt von jesus und wenn sie dann
darüber hinaus anschauen warum
thematisiert überhaupt der koran das
leben jesu die geburt von jesus die
besonderheit von diego seine geistigkeit
das ist er ist eine herausragende figur
des korans warum eigentlich
wenn sie darüber hinaus weiter gehen und
sehen bei allen muslimischen mystikern
dies überhaupt gegeben hat
alle haben jesus gelebt und mit jesus
gearbeitet
jesus als motiv der der einfachheit der
der armut jesus als einer der auf dem
weg war die vision der maria maria als
inbegriff der reinheit und liebe und
hingabe wir hätten gerne noch übersehen
und bleiben wir bei jesus oder gerade
bei diesem weg des jesus führt das ist
ein weg aber da bleiben wir stehen
sondern das ist auch ein weg und ich
kann als muslim ist sehr gut an meinen
jesus halten weil er auch ein
unglaublich beseelte persönlichkeit
gewesen ist wenn man so ausdrücken will
der zum islam gehört jetzt aber muss ich
sie schon fragen ob es für sie nicht
eine provokation ist wenn papa an sein
schreibt das und damit vertreter
natürlich auch die christliche theologie
insgesamt das eben christus der erlöser
sei ist ja schon im begriff erlöser der
menschheit und selbst wenn man ihn ja
nicht bekennt ist dies also das ist ja
eigentlich eine provokation für die für
den islam um nicht nur für den smarten
diese ansprung ja aber wieso
provokationen schlimmste als
wirtschaftskommunikation auf sondern
denken dass das
dieser glaube da ist aber provokationen
wird es nur dann wenn er jetzt behaupten
würde glaube du auch da dran
dann würde sein jetzt stoppt also da ist
die grenze erreicht haben so fern von
mir auch mir das schreiben mit ihnen nur
dann ein buch wenn sie erwähnte zu
diesem ergebnis ist also nicht der weg
vielmehr dass mich das positiv
provoziert und die positive provokation
besteht darin dass ich mich frage was
eigentlich damit meint was bedeutet
erlösung was bedeutet für die
christenheit jesu und was bedeutet
überhaupt das kreuz wie muslime können
damit nicht viel anfangen weil es
einfach in unsere eigene inkulturation
religiöser art so etwas nicht nicht
positiv besetzt ist aber ich merke da
geht es ja nicht eigentlich um jesus
denn es geht um gott
es geht um eine sehnsucht die durch
jesus artikuliert ist wenn das damit
gesagt ist und jesus nicht ein anderer
von gott ist dann kann ich das sehr gut
verstehen um gleich ich das in dieser
form nicht artikulieren würde und sie
merken dass hilft was hilft uns hilft
uns der weg der spiritualität deshalb
weil wir nach der geistigkeit suchen und
ich bei differenzen stehen bleiben daran
erkranken eigentlich die meisten dialoge
weil sie glauben okay ich glaube daran
nicht und dann gehen wir wieder
ausgenommen
ich möchte trotzdem noch eine differenz
betonen mohammed wird als siegel der
propheten beschrieben und er bestätigt
zwar dass judentum und das christentum
aber gleichzeitig korrigiert er ist ja
wie stehen sie zu machen mit gut ist als
prophet ob getreten dass er als
herausforderung eines christen auch ob
ihr christlich genug leben
dass für dich so sehen damals war ich
zufrieden mit dem was gelebt worden ist
und insofern ist es als herausforderung
dass wir uns als christen tragen wollten
wir diesen jesus genügend nach und und
dem kasten der bibel steht
oder müssen wir auch immer wieder neu
die augen öffnen das insofern würde ich
ein
als herausforderung sehen ohne dass ich
dann inhaltlich seine seine einige
inhalte kann können wir christen ja auch
teilen betonte wieder auch die
barmherzigkeit so weiter
da sind wir uns ja auch einige aber ohne
dass ich seine theologie teile als
weckruf
als prophetischer weckruf für uns
christen konnte den büros akzeptieren
ich möchte gern noch weiter gehen zur
figur maria sie hatten sie zuvor schon
auch angesprochen sie kommt im koran
explizit vor die einzige frau die
namentlich erwähnt wird
das finde ich erstaunlich deswegen kann
das sein dass das nicht mal eva die
kommt ja quasi erst aus den anderen
tradition dazu nicht mal eva wird
namentlich genannt ja das sind die
geheimnisse des korans um dieses land
soll das ist auch etwas ganz besonderes
maria maria wird erwähnt oder auch
gewürdigt als einer der wenigen frauen
die es überhaupt gibt auf der ganzen
welt
selbst der prophet wenn sie als einer
von den vier besten frauen und sie wird
als vor allem die betonung ist auch als
frau nicht er ist einfach nicht so als
manager und insbesondere als seine frau
zu würdigen diese frauengestalt di maria
in sich trägt diese hingabe die sie hat
die ist überwältigend für auch für
muslimische geistigkeit frömmigkeit
tradition
aber sehen sie nicht dass es da ein
problem das ist ja in christentum sehr
ähnlich nur dass wir da mehrere frauen
bilder haben rollenbild dass sie ein
unerreichbares rollenbild aber damit ist
nicht gesagt alle ehefrauen ich muss so
sein wie maria und gerade das sie können
hier nicht weil maria ist nur einmal
gibt sondern maria ist auch ein
idealvorstellung maria ist auch immer
ein sprachbild ein motiv anvisieren
genauso wie jesu oder moose oder abraham
sie sind wir einen propheten aber auch
als figuren die immer bis heute noch uns
etwas zu sagen haben
wie maria des korans ist keine tote
maria sind die mafia des korans lebt in
meiner in meiner unruhe
weil ich mich immer wieder frage was
hätte maria gemacht wie hätte maria
darauf machen sie das persönlich gehört
mag ich es in meinem religiösen leben
also wenn die super mariens in dem koran
ist einer der schönsten suchen und die
die wir tauchen sehr gerne zitierten in
moscheen mit bedacht im monat ramadan
und naja also da wird kann ich diese
differenzierung vorgenommen
ich habe das gelesen wir maria hat mich
sehr gefreut dass der koran so positiv
hier sieht natürlich wenn die geschichte
schauen im christentum gibt es viele
fälschungen auch von maria dass man
frauen bild projiziert hat maria und es
den frauen über gespielt hat aber wenn
man ehrlich ist im mittelalter war hier
auch positives bild frauen nicht nur die
mutter sondern die schöne frau die
königin die die fruchtbare braune die
madonna also die belesene frau also die
ziel ist ständig also das war eine ganz
wichtige bilder auch von positiven
frauenbilder aber durch alles kann
verfälscht werden also so wie bei jesus
verniedlicht hat so hat man nach ihren
asexuell gesehen und so weiter und das
waren dann alles für beziehungen aber
die alten traditionen diese für die
christen theologen und das frühe
mittelalter hatte das waren sehr
optimistische und die marien feste sind
alles optimistische feste und es gibt
dich
aggressive marienverehrer die sehr
konservativ sind aber die eigentliche
dahin tradition der kirche ist das sehr
optimistisches und das poetische sehr
die bilder von maria salve regina und so
das sind ist poesie
ich wollte eigentlich kann ich sagen
dass irgendwie pessimistisch sein
sondern dass das problem er hat das
jenige ist dass man eine person sollen
zentrum stellt die gewissermaßen schon
fast von heiligkeit überformt ist weil
sie eine auserwählte ist und weil sie
attribute hat die für eine gewöhnliche
sterbliche frau nicht erreichbar sind
und da komme ich zum nächsten punkt was
sie natürlich in den stolpersteinen und
ganz grundsätzlich als vertreter ihrer
religion sich einmal wieder hören
das ist einfach die diskriminierung der
frau in den religionen stellt heutzutage
sehr viele fragezeichen und was muss
sich verändern damit wir nicht mehr
dieses frauenbild haben das von von
religion scheinbar kolportiert wird
maria ist nicht davon ein frauenbild den
frauen überstürzt und die positive war
in theologie ist dass marian tipps für
den lösten menschen für jeden menschen
so dass wir uns sehen können in ihren
nicht nicht sie haben zu kleben und
unerreichbar ist das alles was von maria
gesagt hat ein bild für uns ist das auch
die ganzen trocken sind bilder von uns
aber gut die frauen dimension
diskriminierung dem katholischen
bereitwillig teilweise liberalismus
zusammen
dann muss ich ja einiges tun also denkt
das frauenbild des christentums ist
durchaus positiv aber es gab auch immer
wieder gelegenheiten befolgung wo man da
einmal die angst vor der frau dann der
angst vor sexualität
da ist sicher der katholischen tradition
sind und manche oder
reaktionen von anderen strömungen dabei
die man sehr kritisch sehen muss und
wird sich hier noch eine verwandlung da
sind sie dafür dass man im katholizismus
auch priesterinnen einführt ich habe
dich dafür da können wir das nicht
machen also wenn der papst heute sagt
dann wird es für viele ein aufstand
gebnis geschichtlicher prozess aber es
gibt keinen grund dagegen und deswegen
wird der periode die kirche muss sich
darauf bewegen sonst wandern die
früheren haus das hört man immer wieder
genau das auch wichtige frauen aus der
katholischen kirche ausgetreten sind
ich würde gerne bei ihnen auch fragen
ich meine auch im arminen sind ja
durchaus eine minderheit das sind primär
männer die die cold träger sind ja das
ist aber wissen sie die sehr schwierig
zu sagen das bild der frau im islam
weil den islam als subjekt mich zeigt
gibt es ja gar nicht einmal die männer
vornehmlich die ihre religion
interpretieren dass ihm die subjekte
ihre religion und solange nur männer das
sagen haben und früher als ja viel
stärker hier zeigt ist jetzt gravierend
auch abgenommen wie am auto sehen sie
innenminister wir haben 800 studierende
davon über die hälfte dürften frauen
seien
da haben wir neue regeneration die klug
sind die die in keiner weise männern
irgendwie nach gestellt sind und das ist
toll
wir haben das sagen auch eine
perspektive die die womit wir nicht zu
ende sind regelt auch dass die frauen im
auch im islamischen kontext nicht
besonders gut behandelt worden sind in
der geschichte das ist einfach ein
faktum
die frage ist woran liegt das eigentlich
ist natürlich an uns also an männer die
ängste haben die seltsame frauenbilder
haben diese macht nicht aus den händen
geben da gibt es glaube ich an eine
vielzahl von gründen auf der anderen
seite gibt es auch die die die
möglichkeit dass man es ändert das ist
ja nicht festgeschrieben und erinnert
man das in dem auch frauen auch religiös
ihre aufgaben und ihre fragen
kommunizieren dass sie mitdenken mit
interpretieren
aber wir haben jetzt schon gesagt die
hälfte in münster das sind auch frauen
werden die aber wahrscheinlich nicht
alles imam imam ihnen dass das will
seine freiwillige aufgabe zu sein
es gibt tolle es gibt kann auch sehr
vorgang sein aber es gibt auch man kann
auch sieht er im theologisch fördern
sie sollen einfach lieber die
verschuldung macht sein verständnis
haben sie noch viel mehr möglichkeiten
sich mit ihrer religion noch vertiefter
auseinanderzusetzen
da würde sie zunächst einmal sehen ist
ja leicht zu rufen wir brauchen imam ihn
und alle die danach rufen würde ich
fragen nach welcher theologie an ein
weil es mode ist das reicht nicht so
erreicht man nichts sondern sie müssen
das erst einmal grundlegend begreifen
und fragen was bedeutet so etwas sei
niemals zu sein aber werden sie sagen
das ist eine mutter des frauen in einer
mode ohne triologie mode ist ohne
nachgedacht zu haben danach suchen
das stört mich in dieser debatte sondern
ich brauche sozusagen eine eine
durchdachte position die in dieser
hinsicht auch klar artikuliert sein kann
frauen sie in keiner weise menschen
zweiter klasse sie können an keiner
stelle des korans finden wo die frau
nicht dieselben pflichten und
verantwortung und trinkt religiöser
natur wie die männer
sie werden im gleichen atemzug über
einen pflicht genommen und warum sollen
sie auch nicht dass objekte ihrer
religion seien auch religionen vertreten
meine perspektive meine hoffnung ist
dass irgendwann mal nicht nur die frauen
feministischer theologie betreiben
sondern auch männern dass ich mich als
mann für die frauen einsätze das wäre
sozusagen meine hoffnung für die zukunft
eine feministische theologin ist zu
schreiben oder die größere hoffnung wäre
dass das gar nicht mehr notwendig ist
weil das hat vorrang gegeben ist dass
alle mit denen ich merke schon sie
argumentieren sie erklären haben sie in
ihrem dialog für dieses buch auch mal
wirklich gestrickten thematisch beide
sehen wir keine keine aggressiven typen
wir haben was ist ihre meinung aber es
gab keinen streit sondern das war immer
von respekt geprägt
ja in der tat also ich glaube wohl sagen
denn die hauptschwierigkeiten in diesem
dialog klar von vornherein geht es darum
dass du das wesentliche sie haben es ein
paar fragen ja schon angesprochen um
erlösung frage und kreuzestheologie um
die menschwerdung gottes sohn genau
genommen ist ja nicht mein mann geworden
da kann man dann genauer nachfragen
warum ist er ausgerechnet ein mann nicht
eine frau die mich auch interessen und
dann würde man ihn erklären
es ist eigentlich gar nicht seine
helligkeit im vordergrund steht dann
seine menschlichkeit und da merken sie
also jesus sehe ich nicht als ein mann
jesus wenn das im vordergrund da ist
schon etwas verfälscht sondern das muss
so sein geschlecht spielt hier keine
rolle während er so sein als die
offenbarung gottes weiter trägt sondern
seine humanität da sind auf jeden fall
mit perspektiven die man öffnen kann ich
glaube deswegen ist das buch so
argumentativ so sein weil wir nicht nur
einander belehren wollen weil da können
wir beide informations bücher zum
einführung in christus oder islam lesen
sondern versuchen aufeinander zuzugehen
und da eine tiefere möglichkeit der
begegnung zu schaffen
und da ist streit sind natürlich auch
beim stück erscheinen da aber ein streit
der sozusagen von geistigkeit geprägt
ist
wir sind bald am ende ich möchte noch
wissen sie haben hier auf theoretischer
ebene miteinander diskutiert über die
religion haben sie sich auch überlegt
eine praktische ebene einzuführen zum
beispiel zusammen zu beten zu sagen ein
quasi gottesdienst zu machen haben wir
eigentlich nicht so geplant aber das ist
uns meinen glaub ich nicht sehr fremd
nichts zu tun
da wird am kirchentag
da wird natürlich in erster linie um
dialog hin aber das andere gemeinsam
gottesdienst feiern und wesentliche
dinge gemeinsam zu tun
das kann ich mir gut vorstellen das war
jetzt in dem man nicht
ich habe eine letzte frage an sie
glauben den christen und muslime an
denselben gott natürlich es gibt nur
einen gott
es gibt verschiedene bilder ende hin
wird ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich pater
an seinem heck karimi für dieses
wunderbare gespräche nächste woche
zeigen wir ihnen an dieser stelle den
film wohin mit dem kreuz
es ist eine reise durch die schweiz in
der das christentum das leben der
menschen immer weniger bestimmt was hat
das für folgen für den einzelnen und in
der sternstunde philosophie ist jetzt
peter sloterdijk bei meinem kollegen
yves bost zu gast das sollten sie nicht
verpassen
weiterhin eine schon sonntag und auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]